le dim 20 continue voici le rappel des
titres 56 morts 156 blessés instauration
de l'état d'urgence le caucase sombre
dans la guerre civile
la cavale est terminée pour les dvd de
brest didier masson et stéphanie toutain
ont été arrêtés à bordeaux nous
consacrerons également une très large
place au festival du cinéma fantastique
d'avoriaz vous ils rejoindront en direct
henry chapier qui se trouve aux côtés de
l'invité d'honneur du festival
tony curtis des chars d'assaut et des
grenades en plus des mitrailleuses et
des hélicoptères c'est l'incroyable
potentiel militaire dont dispose
aujourd'hui les nationalistes azéri et
arménien qui s'affrontent dans le
caucase c'est l'armée rouge maintenant
qui devra tenter de mettre fin à ce
conflit où ils les forces de l'ordre
soviétique dépêchés sur place ont
commencé aujourd'hui à appliquer l'état
d'urgence décrété hier soir par le
kremlin
dans les régions les plus exposées dans
le caucase on n'hésite plus à parler
d'une véritable guerre civile
rémy gullit shelly
scènes de guerre dans une ville du
centre de l'azerbaïdjan mais ces soldats
qui tirent en l'air pour disperser des
manifestants trou violon arrive bien
tard au cours des quatre derniers jours
56 personnes en majorité des arméniens
ont été tués à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de là dans les rues de bakou
sur les bords de la mer caspienne dans
le haut-karabakh où des combats se
poursuivent ce soir la confusion est à
son comble isolé est traqué par les
azéri les arméniens qui vivent dans
cette enclave montagneuses ont pourtant
critiqué tout comme leurs agresseurs
l'état d'urgence décrété hier soir à
moscou
les unités de l'armée de la marine et du
kgb qui arrivent ici pour renforcer les
troupes du ministère de l'intérieur sont
considérés dans les deux camps comme des
envahisseurs
mireille corbacho se retrouve donc face
à une double impasse contraint à mettre
en jeu l'armée rouge
et là vous l'échec d'une politique de
compromis de plus sur le terrain
la temporisation actuelle pourrait
cacher une prochaine flambée de violence
nécessitant un nouvel envoi de troupes
ces armes saisies par l'armée prouve
s'il en était besoin qu'on est bien ici
en état de guerre et dans les montagnes
du haut karabakh de véritables milices
se sont constitués bien armés et
beaucoup plus motivés qu'une armée fait
de conscrits quant à moscou au coeur de
ces montagnes le pouvoir soviétique
semble ce soir bien dilué face au
nationalisme et à la violence
gorbatchev n'a plus qu'une issue
reprendre l'initiative politique pour
maintenir chacun dans leur camp armenia
est assez riche
oui nous avons blanchi l'argent de la
drogue c'est l'aveu ce soir d'une banque
luxembourgeoise la bci qui accepte par
ailleurs une mise à l'épreuve de cinq
ans assorti d'une perte d'actifs
d'environ 80 millions de francs aveux
formulés devant le tribunal de miami aux
états unis deux filiales de la bcc y
avait été inculpé par la justice
américaine d' association de malfaiteurs
en vue du blanchiment de 180,2 millions
de francs pour le compte du cartel de
medellin
voici à présent les télégrammes de
l'étranger avec les commentaires de
laurence piquet
au moins trois morts à l'issue d'une
tentative d'évasion au palais de justice
de blida 50 km d'alger
quatre détenus se sont enfermés dans une
salle d'audience avec plusieurs otages
la police a ordonné l'assaut un gendarme
et 2 des prisonniers ont été tués des
milliers de personnes réunies sur la
place venceslas à prague première
cérémonie officielle en l'honneur de jan
polak cet étudiant de 21 ans qui s'était
immolé par le feu pour protester contre
l'invasion des troupes soviétiques
son geste n'a pas été vain a déclaré
vaclav havel alexandre do check arrivée
à strasbourg pour recevoir le prix
sakharov décerné par le parlement
européen
c'est sa première visite à l'étranger
depuis son élection à la présidence du
parlement tchécoslovaque première séance
à sofia de la table ronde gouvernement
opposition sur l'avenir de la bulgarie
un ordre du jour bouleversé par les
revendications de l'opposition
elle réclame l'accès aux médias et
l'ouverture de bureaux à sofia les deux
parties doivent se retrouver jeudi
enfin triste et surréaliste cette image
dite d'un hippopotame de trois tonnes
lâcher sur cette route anglaise il va se
rendait dans un safari quand le
chargement a lâché sous son poids hilda
traumatisé par cette mésaventure et par
la dose de tranquillisants ne devrait
pas survivre
en france la cavale est terminée pour
les évadés de brest didier masson et
stéphane boutin qui s'était enfui
dimanche dernier de la maison d'arrêt de
pontaniou dans le finistère ils
retourneront dès demain ils ont été
arrêtés ce matin à bordeaux où il est
des hommes qui ont été arrêtés sans
résistance ont été trahis en fait par
leur véhicule volé celui ci avait été
repéré on vendait de bordeaux josiane
beaud hier cette voiture c'est le grain
de sable qui a enrayé la cavale des deux
évadés de bresse quarante huit heures
après leur évasion il circulait toujours
à son bord alors que son signalement est
le leur
et bien sûr était diffusée à tous les
services de police repéré ce matin à
proximité de la gare de bordeaux par des
gendarmes
elle était aussitôt placée sous
surveillance par les hommes de la sûreté
urbaine peine une heure après notre
arrivée les services de la brigade
criminelle et inspecteur de police de la
brigade criminelle de la sûreté ont
remarqué des allures suspect de deux
individus dont il connaissait des
signalements signalements qui
correspondait à ce qui avait été
communiqué par la police judiciaire de
brest
ils ont laissé tourner autour de la
voiture et en toute sécurité
ils ont interpellé larmes au point avec
un précaution bien sûr que les incidents
qui a eu le nez
les deux évadés arrivé à bordeaux dans
la nuit avait tout simplement dormi dans
cet hôtel du quartier de la gare qu'il
quittait en fin de matinée réveiller la
chambre veut dire aucun problème vers
12h30 les clients tout à fait ordinaire
tout assez vraiment font rien parce que
c'était des brigands peut-être à chaque
fois conduit à l'hôtel de police les
deux évadés doivent être entendus par
les enquêteurs de la pj de brest avant
d'être vraisemblablement présenté au
parquet de bordeaux puis ramené dans le
finistère voici maintenant venu le tour
de france de l'actualité avec les
commentaires de nathalie et heures
manifestation cet après midi des
professeurs de collège à saint lô dans
la manche
motif suppression de 45 postes alors que
la rentrée 90 prévoit 117 postes
supplémentaires dans les lycées cette
décision ferait passer l'effectif moyen
d'une classe de 3e de 24 à 30 élèves
pour les manifestants il n'y a aucune
raison de favoriser les lycées au
détriment des collèges
rebondissement dans la sphère de la
maison rasée de madame brisseau l'ordre
de démolition aurait été donnée par
michel falicon deuxième adjoint au maire
de nice et président de la société
immobilière de la ville
rappelons que madame brisseau avait
porté plainte contre l'un de ses fils
qui avaient signé une résiliation de
bail sans son accord à la suite de cela
elle avait été agressée puis hospitalisé
m
plâtre et des parcs m les internes
rennais font preuve d'imagination pour
donner force à leurs revendications
ainsi la nuit dernière ils ont plâtre et
quelques 300 parcmètres et horodateurs
du centre ville une manière de
populariser leur mouvement
quatre d'entre eux ont cependant été
interpellés et entendus par la police
trop de chats errants à montpellier
c'est ce qu'a constaté madame jeanne qui
du coup leur a offert l'hospitalité de
puiseaux rôle et au mini doux et les
autres font studio commun au total 120
chats qui attend de l'adoption
évidemment ceci n'est pas du goût de
tous les voisins certains ont préféré
partir à l'hôtel
nous avons maintenant une grande page
consacré au cinéma fantastique le 18e
festival d'avoriaz nous allons rejoindre
en direct en réchappe ix et henri avant
d'accueillir tony curtis
le jury du festival serait invitée cette
année a consacré la fin de la suprématie
anglo saxon c'est le réveil du cinéma
français oui tout à fait parce qu'il ya
trois français présents ici et si vous
voulez il y à un virage au niveau des
goûts du public et des sélectionneurs du
festival de festivals à 18 ans et les
verts globine ça suffit volage qui se
sont dit qu'on va revenir un peu
l'étrange la tendresse et nous avons
surtout comme gay stage nous assistons à
un renouveau total d'arguments pour les
stages et tony curtis qui nous fait
vraiment honneur d'être avec nous ce
soir
sade est aperçu de ce phénomène qui lui
rappelle les années merveilleuses de
soldats qui trotte certains l'aiment
chaud
tony kart il s'avère plutôt ça va bien
dit you how to know if you lui à l'az à
mathieu fred flavio à peu mais c'est
bien d'un cube fun labs hockey
tadic est vraiment désolation partout où
il passe non à wellington sud est turc
en tout bien fait de vrais devient brun
et tandis que tissent regarder ceux ci
ça vous rappelle quelqu'un c'est
évidemment marilyn way et volaille to
know why did you ricol c'est la première
peinture que j'ai fait de ce que
j'appelle une femme je ferai tout les
fans romands de marilyn monroe jusqu'à
tchèque klemme all there is it should he
is like titane dans la soirée
tavaux 60 villes de la planète hillys
d'être fois deux faisaient toujours
l'acteur sera d'avoir deux métiers que
je pratique aux 23 médailles tramoni tu
marques un métier de jouer avec lui à
monaco ap h au pilote et je crois aussi
devenir docteur visite au cambodge un
gynécologue dit il en rit on revient sur
cette nouvelle tendance affichée avoriaz
qui sont donc ces français qui
révolutionne ce 18e festival est bien
les seuils que mr thing cremona
l actrice alors les français dont on
parle ici d'avant rené manzor rené
manzor qui est qui a fait ses preuves
déjà avec le film que qui a été produit
par l'un d'eux non revient ici avec un
sujet tout à fait différent vous allez
on voit quelques images ces 36 15 codes
36 cas ce père noël
c'est un film assez stone age
père noël le film rené manzor est ce que
vous avez eu dans l'idée que des vies si
fier le père noël ça pourrait coûter
cher
peut-être mais en tout cas si vous
voulez moi je me suis pas posé le
problème comme ça je pense que
aujourd'hui le père noël est un
personnage qui n'a plus du tout les
mêmes valeurs d'autrefois et simplement
ce que je voulais faire s'est posé la
question va faire faire que les parents
puissent se poser la question de ce
qu'est devenu père noël aujourd'hui qui
n'est plus du tout ce personnage
bienveillant par rapport aux enfants qui
est finalement un mercenaire qui bouffe
à tous les râteliers qui est un
personnage vendeur très vendeur une
image très très très très vendeuse pour
la société de consommation et qui n'est
plus du tout en aucune façon lié aux
enfants il ya d'autres personnages si
vous voulez dans le merveilleux jeux
sont plus proches des enfants je pense
aux elfes au magicien qui n'ont rien eu
à nous vendre en tout cas alors il faut
que vous sachiez que ce film est tout à
fait magique mais qu'il est aussi cruel
c'est un film qui a divisé opinio parce
qu'il ya un enfant qui est un danger il
joue le rôle d'un petit grand beau il y
est absolument fabuleux et moi je crois
que ce film va très bien marché bien au
delà d'avoriaz
alors l'autre en français c'est un
tendre c'est bernard a cuit et son film
s'appelle tom et lola c'est une histoire
tendre de deux bébés qui ont vécu sous
une bulle pratiquement il essaie de s'en
libérer
regardez ces images c'est la poésie
tueur vraiment
ma mère vous attendez j'étais sûr que
vous alliez revenir aux petites phrases
une tortue les petits connards en fait
j'y pense tous les soirs six mois cet
ensemble
tu sais bien que c'est trop tour tu ton
prix ne recommence pertes attendues et
henri iv y nous avons également une page
concernant les cias de l'est a oui oui
oui c'est ce que je voulais vous dire
justement signe de l'évolution politique
on assiste aussi à l'émergence d'un
cinéma fantastique dans ces pays
devaient d'abord nous on apprend à
connaître quelques films qu'on n'avait
pas pu voir il ya des films hongrois des
films tchèques des films soviétiques
aussi mais si vous voulez ce qui est
intéressant fait qu' ils vont venir
sûrement l'année prochaine avec des
films tout à fait nouveau et je vous
propose d'écouter polanski roman
polanski qui nous livre son opinion à
lui et ses impressions sur ce problème
romane polanski il ya quelques années
seulement le cinéaste des pays de l'est
vont pouvoir de profiter un peu de la
technologie d'ici qui vont peut-être
venir non france en allemagne en
angleterre je serai kadri à plat est ce
que l on pourrait dire qu'ils ont
toujours été libre renault à part
quelques années difficiles vous écris ça
vous semble peut être d'ici mais vivre à
l'intérieur de ça c'est très difficile
parce que ce que vous percevez ici ce
sont des petits d'explosion de liberté
et qui ont coûté parfois des têtes
non on peut va dire qu'on était disons
que la pologne donné un peu plus de
liberté à leurs créateurs que les autres
pays de l'est mais mais il y avait quand
même ils censurent impitoyable et l'a
fait terminer à lacets comblement
terminer là c'est comme l'ont terminée
et bizarrement on dirait qu'il ya un peu
moins de cathy vite et en ce moment ce
qui veut dire surtout c'est que les
polonais comme les autres cinéastes de
lettres mortes d'autres
technologie avancée hier ils ont bien
sûr déçu et caméras mais ils veulent
savoir plus alors dans trois jours on va
connaître le palmarès de ce festival
alors vous qui savez tous henry qui est
parti pour remporter cette 18e édition
qu'il favorise d'abord n'a pas du tout
les films et je vous dirais que je crois
que ce sera un anglo saxons ce à paris
quand même normal parce qu'on va pas
transformée en festival antipathique à
ceux sur ce poids là mais il y aura
probablement certainement appris pour
l'un des français ou un autre européen
peut pas volonté politique mais parce
que je crois qu'ils adorent renouveau
qui correspond aux tuniques à nous et
avoriaz à 18 ans c'est l'âge adulte
donc c'est un festival respectable qui
veut pas compter que sur leurs frissons
et les claques qu'on donne à son voisin
fera stone est mort de peur
voilà ce que j'ai à vous dire sans vous
n'avez des titres personnage puis vite
n'a pas vu les films que nous allons
nous-mêmes découvrir ce soir est un des
trois jours à venir animaux henry
concernant le jury ce festival - tony
curtis invité d'honneur
un jury prestigieux cette année encore
ah oui vous avez bien vu il ya vos airs
est qu il y à ray bradbury
il y avait des gens vraiment que le pays
connaît mille sont choisis venant
d'horizons toute assez divers y avons
investi en fait il y a quinze noms qui
disent quelque chose à différents
publics aux jeunes et aux moins jeunes
bref à tout le monde
si vous laisse la spécialité d'avoriaz
fait que le jury vie même c'est un jour
ici tard et la station disons à nos
quand même regarder des neiges est
certes roi lion vous montre avec tout
son talent la neige ce n'est pas de la
neige carbonique c'est de la soie il
existe quand même là on veut merci henri
pour cette présentation finalement assez
complète de ce qu'est le festival du
film fantastique d'avoriaz 18e édition
et michel touré dans quelques minutes de
vous connecter minutes même quelques
secondes pratiquement vous confirmera
que la neige arrive tout doucement sur
les montagnes françaises
le programme de la soirée sur l'a3 alors
soir 3 présenté par notre ami philippe
dessaint 22h15 suivi par un très beau
film de bertolucci
c'est maintenant la fin de cette édition
c'est la dernière édition que nous avons
eu le plaisir de vous présenter ensemble
avec catherine à partir de lundi vous
retrouverez catherine tous les après
midi toutes les heures de l'après midi
celle qui aura la responsabilité de tous
les flashs d'informations je vous
retrouverai pour ma part désormais pour
les éditions l'actualité du week-end
notamment pour le tout nouveau 19/20
dimanche qui commencera le dimanche 28
jan et comme nous aimons bien compliqué
les choses dont je vous dirai au revoir
jeudi prochain on se retrouve dès cette
fin de semaine sera assurée par gérard
pinson
je vous remercie en tout cas d'être
resté fidèle au 19/20 pendant sept
longues années que nous avons passées
ensemble
merci de le rester encore à toutes les
éditions d'information de la 3 à bientôt
donc
bonsoir bonsoir à demain toujours de la
péniche de thalassa
qui